we would we allow novak djokovic
to uh take part at wimbledon if he
wasn't vaccinated
sorry k you were asking about novak
djokovic and wimbledon um well again
there's a as we've just heard there's a
complex process going on in australia we
have to respect the integrity of that
process
and wimbledon is some months away the
thing i would say to anyone is that it
is good to get vaccinated it is good for
you it is good for others good for
society um but uh with the specific case
of mr djokovic well i'll leave it to the
australian authorities to decide that
for the moment um and as i say uh there
are plenty of sporting highlights before
we reach wimbledon bit of swerve on that
backhand are we ready to live with kovid
here in the uk
i think we are getting ready to live
with covet absolutely um i think that uh
what's been striking is the success of
the booster campaign um
while there are with novak djokovic one
or two high-profile figures who uh uh
themselves haven't been vaccinated the
overwhelming good sense of the british
people has meant that um
millions of us
have been vaccinated have had our
booster and as a result we've been
playing our part in making sure that we
relieve the pressure on the nhs and make
sure that care is there for those who
need it
and we're ready to cut the isolation
period from seven to five days
sorry k i i just missed that because i'm
afraid that i think i had your producer
in my ear rather than you i'm so sorry
oh i'm sorry about that i'm just asking
as a result are we saying that we are
ready to cut the isolation period from
seven days to five days
well we always keep these things under
review um and the most important thing i
think is to ensure that we are uh
we are in a position to uh protect uh
the nhs and to protect public services
so we at the moment are in a position
where we've reduced the uh isolation
period as you know from ten to seven
days we'll keep that under review um but
it will be the health secretary and the
prime minister who will make any
announcement in due course not me
it does sound as though the cabinet is
open to it though
well we always keep things um under
review because we're always guided by
the facts by the science and by uh
changing circumstances so
i think it's striking to note that in
the united kingdom overall particularly
in england we have one of the most um uh
open regimes one of the uh essentially
one of the uh most liberal approaches of
any country in europe but we also need
to balance that with a determination to
ensure that we are not overwhelming the
nhs um and your question gives me an
opportunity just to say thank you to
everyone who's been working on the nhs
front line for nearly two years now to
deal with this epidemic uh their uh
their hard work their dedication their
sacrifices um uh are amazing um and
we're all in their debt
yep we certainly are um you say we're
guided by the science as far as being
led by the government is concerned one
wonders how much notice
we should be taking of the modeling the
latest modelling that we
saw from the london school of tropical
medicine they were suggesting that worst
case scenario we would see something
like 75 000 deaths from the omicron
variant by the end of april the latest
figures that we had from the 23rd of
december particularly for omicron were
14 deaths as opposed to 75 000. isn't it
time we we stopped going with the worst
case scenario
well i think we need to look at a range
of scenarios um and it's always the case
that we look at uh uh different academic
models models by their very definition
are not predictions um they just run
through what is likely to happen and
again at different stages in this
pandemic sorry to interrupt mr go but
likely to happen 14 deaths as opposed to
75 000 come on
sorry okay once again i'm afraid i heard
your producer or or one of the excellent
technical team in sky just speaking in
my ear there so i i missed your question
i do apologize
not at all i'm sorry about that i was
saying there's a big difference between
14 deaths and 75 000 some people would
say that potentially was scare-mongering
no i don't think it's scaremongering at
all and no one is setting out to
scaremonger what we are always setting
out to do is to ensure that we are in a
position to model a range of scenarios
and to be ready for um uh those
different outcomes i think it would be a
mistake not to model some scenarios
where the nhs is under very severe
pressure so that we can make sure that
the resources are there i think it would
be irresponsible not to have a range of
scenarios because we need to be in a
position where uh we can cope with uh uh
however the virus mutates however the
epidemic develops um and that's why it
is right that we have these scenarios
but it's also the case and and you're
right here as well that we stress that
these are models they are not
predictions
um
how long will lateral flow tests be free
as long as we need them
and how long do you think that might be
again one of the things about the
pandemic is that it's been impossible to
predict with certainty throughout but it
is the case that in this country lateral
flow tests are free and unlike in in
many other jurisdictions they're a vital
tool in making sure that we can curb the
spread of the infection and also the
people who need to isolate do so but as
as you pointed out right at the very
beginning of our conversation we are
moving to a situation we're not there
yet but we are moving to a situation
where it is possible to say that we can
live with covid and that the pressure on
the nhs and on vital public services is
abating but
it's absolutely vital to recognize that
we are not there yet and as the health
secretary has reminded us there will be
some difficult weeks ahead and that is
why we all need to continue to test
continue if we are positive to isolate
and continue broadly to support the nhs
as it goes through a challenging period
um but one in which uh the frontline
professionals are doing an amazing job
so we are considering phasing out
lateral flow tests but not for the
coming weeks as we continue to try to
deal with the omicron variant and indeed
the delta variant that is still around
over the next few weeks so not for the
next few weeks in other words is that
right
as as the prime minister and others have
said we will do whatever it takes
talk to me about why you're here today
which is um cladding
uh four billion pounds um to help those
people that are basically stuck in homes
that are unsafe or they can't sell them
um is it going to be a voluntary scheme
for these developers to get involved
well we want to say to developers and
indeed to all those who have a uh a role
to play in recognizing their
responsibility that we want to work with
them um but if it's the case that uh
it's necessary to do so then we will use
legal means and ultimately if necessary
the tax system in order to ensure that
uh those who have deep pockets those who
are responsible for the upkeep of these
buildings pay rather than the
leaseholders the individuals who are in
the past were being asked uh to pay with
money they didn't have for a problem
that they did not cause
so you're saying that there could be a
developer's tax and you would bring in
the full weight of the law to make sure
that they cough up
yes and i think it's important to look
to this in a balanced way there are some
developers um some people in the
property business uh who have been
stepping up to the plate already living
up to their responsibilities removing
dangerous cladding making sure that
buildings are safe i applaud that work
uh but there are others uh who still
have more to do and it's a
straightforward question
should it be those with uh the big bucks
the big profits um uh who have been
responsible for the construction of
these buildings and who are uh the
ultimate owners of these buildings or
should it be individuals uh who have
worked hard in order to get a mortgage
and who are now being saddled with costs
for faults that were not their
responsibility
if you put the question like that then i
think there can only be one answer
what about people in buildings that have
got the challenges with problems other
than cladding insulation wooden
balconies etc etc the dc-lg committee
estimated sorting out fire defects could
cost something like 15 billion pounds
are you going to be looking at that as
well
we are i'm i i think the thing about the
costs there is that we've just been
talking about modeling and estimates and
so on i don't think the costs would be
anything like that but i do think it is
necessary to make sure that um the
buildings are safe i think it's also
important to bear in mind though um that
the uh overwhelming majority of
buildings which are not high-rise
buildings uh are safe um and uh it's
important that we get a proper sense of
proportion that we make sure firstly
that we get rid of dangerous cladding
that we make those buildings which are
currently unsafe totally safe but at the
same time with other buildings that uh
uh
have been considered uh to be in scope
of particular types of work it's
important that we also get a sense of
proportion back because one of the
problems that uh that many people living
in flats face is that at the moment
there is a question mark hanging over
the safety of their flats that means
they can't get a mortgage um or others
who want to buy the fat count get a
mortgage and they can't move on and what
we want to do is to tackle the real
dangers and restore a sense of
proportion
and in addition to that they're
struggling to pay their energy bills um
should we be cutting v80
on energy bills
well again i think it's important that
we look at a range of options here in
order to to help um and the government
already provides additional support for
those who
are in uh
particular difficulties
we have warm homes payments there are
other ways in which we support people so
i think it's important when we are
thinking about how we help people that
we look at ways in which we can target
our support most effectively on those
most in need
is that a yes or no to cutting that on
bills as far as you're concerned
well i think we should always seek to
cut taxes whenever we can but also it's
important when we are providing support
for people though we also target it most
on those who need it most
so cutting vat on energy bills is
something that you would support
well i i you know in my view
the more we can cut taxes the better but
at this point i think that the
the prudent and the responsible thing to
do is to recognize um that we need to
take a balanced approach and a balanced
approach means that when we can support
we provide support most to those in the
most difficult circumstances
so particularly on energy bills at the
moment given that some people could find
themselves uh with a bill going up more
than 600 quid
well i think that's precisely why we
should be concentrating our support
most on uh those with the uh uh the
least income um the least where with all
uh in order to be able to
meet those and other bills and that's
what we do we target support uh whether
it is through warm homes payments or
through
other interventions on those who are
most in need and i think uh most people
would recognize that if we do have uh
ultimately sold taxpayers money if we do
have taxpayers money
to be able to provide people with
support then it should be directed
towards those who are in the toughest
circumstances
talk to me about the parties that um
seem to keep going on at uh number 10 um
downing street it looks as though there
were more taking place on the 20th of of
may last year were you invited
um uh i can't remember what i was doing
on the 20th
last year uh okay
did you go to last year no no no no no
no uh very very few km
two things that i would say
uh no uh i think it's important to
stress that
all of these matters are being
investigated by sugree
um a brilliant civil servant someone who
will investigate without fear or favor
um sue is a permanent secretary in the
department where i'm a minister i don't
think it would be proper for me to say
anything other than uh everyone knows
that she is a person of great integrity
someone who will investigate this
remorselessly and whose conclusions we
should wait for and until we get those
conclusions uh i shouldn't attempt to
preempt it and nor should anyone else
okay let me just ask you one final
question before i let you go more than a
million people have now signed a
position petition i should say saying
that they don't want tony blair to
receive
a knighthood why are they all wrong
well i don't want to get into an
argument with a million people now okay
but one of the things that i would say
is that while uh tony blair uh is a
prime minister whose record uh as any
prime minister who was in power for 10
years uh will it has a record which
divides i think we should all recognize
that he served this country he continues
to serve this country uh and uh i don't
think it's possible for anyone to be in
a position like that without attracting
controversy um um and without um
inviting opposition but um uh for myself
if i look back at uh tony blair's record
uh well there are aspects of it with
which i can disagree i think any
fair-minded person would say that he was
an outstanding statesman and performer
and as a prime minister who uh put
public service first
this recognition from her majesty is
entirely appropriate which particular
aspects did you disagree with
um well we could be here for another um
hour or so if we ran through all of the
things which tiny bird did with which i
disagreed on those things which he did
which um i think were worthwhile um i
think uh uh it's more important to
accentuate the positive in anyone's
record and so i would say that uh the
establishment of academy schools and
more choice in education was a good
thing um i think it was also the case
that the approach he took on being uh
determined to crack down on crime and
anti-social behavior even if it wasn't
always delivered effectively was right
and i also think that uh
his recognition of the importance of a
country like the united kingdom being on
the side of liberty internationally was
also right
okay i'm sorry about the technical uh
challenges i do apologize for that one
way of getting around that of course is
for you to come into the studio next
time so i look forward to seeing you
very soon thank you